[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre pour ce nouvel
entretien à politique sur tv soixante
dix huit premiers pour cette année 2022
qui sera riche en rendez vous électoraux
présidentielle d'abord puis législatives
je reçois aujourd'hui leur en sommes aux
gestes bonjour et bienvenue en plateau
vous êtes la référence du parti
reconquête dans les yvelines formation
d'eric zemmour vous annoncer avoir dans
le département déjà plus d'une centaine
d'adhérents est ce qu'on peut connaître
un petit peu ces militants leur profil
qui vous a rejoint pour cette campagne
non nous sommes actuellement 130 mais
c'est vrai que ça change tous les jours
parce que les gens sortent sortent de
terre c'est un mouvement vraiment qui
est très très fort et qui correspondant
les personnes qui font partie de notre
équipe il y a beaucoup de personnes qui
n'ont jamais été vraiment faim était
peut-être intéressé par la politique
mais des déçus de la politique ça
vraiment c'est la partie la plus la plus
importante de l'effectif de notre équipe
et puis vous avez aussi des personnes
qui viennent d'autres partis tout à fait
mais les vous avez des gens de
différents partis des républicains des
conservateurs des gens devient qui
travaillent avec nous mais évidemment si
vous savez que nous travaillons avec
jean frédéric poisson les conservateurs
laurence rochât qui nous a rejoint aussi
donc tout ça ça donne une bonne équipe
ce qui reste le plus le plus intéressant
peut-être c'est encore une fois ces gens
qui étaient déçus et qui reviennent avec
un
une envie une attente ces gens on a
senti que c'est d'ailleurs notre quart a
beaucoup qui avait une attente de ce cet
homme politique qui ne fait pas partie
des systèmes qui enfin parle de la
france une façon enracinée dans la
nouvelle partie des déçus justement de
la politique vous avez soutenu par le
passé notamment florian philippot oui
alors j'ai soutenu ponctuellement
florian philippot je ne regrette
absolument rien mais c'était très clair
entre nous c'est très récent je les ai
soutenus parce que je trouvais que
c'était un homme donc comment dire
courageux qui défendent des choses tout
à fait importante mais nous avons un
point de différence de différences
importantes sept-îles et pour la sortie
de l'union européenne en tête de gondole
et que je pense que c'est complètement
contre-productif et que je vais beaucoup
plus valides et de marion maréchal ney à
eghezée moore à dire qu'il faut déjà
avant la possibilité de discuter avec un
drop et on a un pied de levier qu'on
peut négocier la hongrie nous montre le
défi pour vous pour votre formation
aujourd'hui c'est aller chercher de
nouveaux militants en séduire plus pour
peser plus avoir les signatures bien sûr
c'est aussi le défi du moment comment
vous allez convaincre ceux qui n'ont pas
encore rejoint à eric zemmour on le voit
aussi dans les intentions de vote il ya
un certain plafonnement de votre
candidat
vous savez vous dites qu'il ya des gens
en effet qui ne sont pas encore décidées
évidemment mais nous on remarque encore
une fois cette venue progressive de tous
les jours en a je vous dis 130 je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on avait une cinquantaine
de contact à traiter et ce soir on sera
peut-être 150 dans l'équipe c'est ces
gens là je le répète et j'insiste
vraiment il y avait une attente mais
hors des schémas politiques le savent et
ça me fait penser à tous ces mouvements
qui ont été créés la droite en dehors
des murs le mouvement souverainiste
laquelle regroupe aussi les tout le tout
le commandeur today tous les partis
politiques de droite comme de gauche
pour essayer de sauver la france cette
douleur de la france qui va mal on l'a
tous depuis des années
personnellement j'ai essayé d'agir avec
des amis de faire des actions qui aimait
qui nous servait qui finalement ont
capoté parce qu'elle n'était pas
incarner
dans un individu qui lui est pétri
d'histoire de france si ça fait quand
même des années kike c'est un
intellectuel qui travaille sur
l'histoire de france qui aime l'histoire
de france et qui est pas que dans une
démarche intellectuelle mais aussi d'une
façon affective et donc nous les gens
qui sont vraiment patriotes qui aimons
la france qu'il qui optent pour sa
continuité historique pour nous c'est
vraiment une réponse une réponse sa
créatrice est une providence de
patriotes le patriotisme pour vous
quelle est votre définition du
patriotisme justement c'est ce qui guide
l'action d'eric zemmour au final donc
quelle est la définition de patriotisme
pour vous écoutez je vais revenir à
cette notion de continuité historique
c'était la continuité historique ou
culturel de la france c'est quelque
chose qui est très important c'est à
dire qu'on ne dit pas qu'on est les
meilleurs on ne dit pas on dit pas qu'il
ya des races supérieures aux autres pour
aller sur des ddd sujets qui font
parfois qui sont très mal traités
d'ailleurs non on dit qu'un pays comme
un être humain doit suivre sa son
évolution organique et évidemment c'est
pas du tout c'est pas du tout statique
c'est pas du tout être passé et
passéiste vouloir être réactionnaire
relire passé c'est tout le contraire
c'est vouloir faire du passé une
continuité heureux en gros c'est un peu
la définition que la tradition la
tradition c'est le choix qui se fait
d'une façon d'une façon spontanée de
notre passé de nos expériences bonnes ou
mauvaises possible de faire quelque
chose de mieux le souci c'est que depuis
quelques décennies nous avons deux
adversaires très percutant nous avons la
grande globalisation du monde le
mondialisme à accent atlantiste
américain et quand on voit que d'antan
des structures d'état en france si on
utilise encore l'anglais
dans des salles de réunion idem dans le
privé alors que des anglais à ma
connaissance ne font même plus partie de
l'union européenne et dans le cadre d'un
échange pour harmoniser et simplifier
les échanges entre les différents défis
en pays pardon à travers le monde aussi
oui mais quand vous avez que des
français quand vous voyez la publicité
de certaines chaînes nommé personne mais
quand on va dire des structures d'état
je pense à vraiment certaine en
particulier qu'ils utilisent l'anglais
ça pose question bref cette grande
globalisation du monde ont dû c'est
cherche à niveler quand même les nations
des changes chez parfait mais vous savez
les changes il est bon quand on sait
qu'ils en aient quand une personne ne
sait pas vraiment qui elle et elle
n'arrive pas à établir une bonne
relation avec les autres états c'est une
évidence les pays c'est a évoqué deux
dangers le second en deux secondes deux
secondes c'est l'islamisation c'est là
et c'est surtout évidemment
d'islamisation mais c'est aussi une
immigration massive
immigration massive qui fait du mal à
tout le monde c'est à dire que les pays
de l'immigration les pays de l'
immigration souffrent parce qu'elles
libèrent de leurs mains et leur cerveau
vous savez il ya des associations
africaines qui luttent contre cette
immigration n'en parle pas parce que
c'est pas dans l'odeur d'une époque mais
c'est une réalité et nous ont rendus
gens malheureux quand il meurt pas en
mer et ils y viennent s'entasser on n'a
pas de travail c'est une tristesse les
gens perdent leur identité
c'est une la défense de cette identité
ya une frontière très près film malgré
tout avec la notion aussi de racisme de
rejet de l'autre lorsqu'on qualifie
votre candidat votre formation de
formation raciste du rejet aussi qu'est
ce que vous répondez c'est tout le
contraire pour moi quand on lutte contre
l'immigration massive c'est qu'on tenait
à
aux antipodes du racisme j'en suis
convaincu on ne veut plus que ces gens
vivent finalement une errance il ya
toujours eu des gens qui ont ils avaient
des situations des destins personnels
une quête parfois personnelles
maintenant c'est une immigration qui est
organisé les passeurs nous le montre
quand même c'est une organisation
presque industrielle j'ai un peu fort
mais c'est quelque chose qui me choque
très profondément et chaque fois il ya
des morts chaque fois il ya des vies qui
étaient des familles qui sont qui sont
complètement disloqué et chez nous on
est malheureux et c'est pas possible on
ne reconnaît plus l'identité de la
personne qui est vraiment pas raciste
c'est une personne qui est contente de
voir que un marocain ne sera pas comme
un armand que valiant qui a des
différences entre les peuples et tant
mieux c'est la diversité est le message
que vous souhaitez faire passer c'est la
base de tout ce que vous nous expliquer
du programme d'eric zemmour aussi je
voudrais juste vous montrer quand même
une vidéo c'était fin décembre
actrice annabelle lengronne c'est une
actrice noire elle a joué dans plusieurs
films elles étaient insultés dans la rue
voilà les propos qu'on lui a tenu et je
voudrais vous faire réagir juste après
si on peut regarder
sur discipline de votre structure oui
mais je jouerai pour faire réagir par
rapport à prendre cette vidéo déjà
cassé mon trop garder notre pays
donc c'était à dax elle a eu le réflexe
de filmer son interlocuteur qui lui a
simplement dit zemmour et ramène dans
ton pays moi j'aime pas les noirs et les
arabes vous comprenez de votre candidat
suscite ce genre de propos est ce que
voulait condamner ces propos vous savez
je pense que dans tous les partis
pour tout les mouvements parce qu'avec
exelmans j'ai plus envie de dire que
c'est un mouvement presque philosophique
anthropologique on est loin d'un aspect
partisans puisque justement il est ici
il est issu d'aucun mouvement partisan
et politicien il ya toujours des gens
qui est qui qui vont dire des sottises
on s'en trouve nez à ses bourreaux qui
se revendique son récit zemmour est élu
mois zemmour c'est visiblement le
candidat de cette personne bien tard que
les zemmouris va être envoyée dans ton
pays gens n'aiment pas les noirs et les
arabes c'est basé sur absolument rien
d'abord eric zemmour je suis désolé mais
il est le symbole même de la simulation
réussi est pas le seul j'en connais
d'autres voilà quand on peut très bien
être d'origine berbère on peut très bien
aimé la france et
s'imprégner de la france et donc c'est
il n'est pas du tout ils jugent pas
d'abri c'est pas du tout de juger les
gens comme ça sur un échange dans la rue
ça c'est simplement 10 à des assauts
d'agressivité basé sur rien et qui
relèvent d'une d'une agressivité abyssal
ça se sentir votre votre candidat
aujourd'hui justement c'est aussi de
véhiculer un certain apaisement on sent
ces propos ils sont plus modérées aussi
il sait qui doit peut-être travailler
sur cette image là il ya une vidéo qui a
été publié annuel par le candidat et il
évoque une égalité des hommes en dignité
une égalité sacré il évoque le fait
qu'il n'y ait pas de race aussi des
propos qu'on n'entendait pas forcément
au tout début de ses premiers pas de
campagne aujourd'hui vous êtes la
stratégie globale ou en tout cas la
façon dont vous allez mener campagne et
plus dans l'apaisement pour aussi
rassuré peut-être c'est plus de
l'explication je pense qu'eric zemmour
depuis des années j'ai bien sûr beaucoup
d'huile avec les mots
il ya quelque chose de très intéressant
chez lui c'est utile et l'approfondît
ses idées donc il peut en changer de
mettre en scène une question de
réflexion mais
on est on est forcément positif
c'est-à-dire que quand on nous assimile
à un mouvement raciste c'est s'est basé
sur i je vous répète que l' immigration
massive c'est ça qui résiste au bout du
monde au bout du compte
les autres propositions aussi de votre
candidat pour avancer un peu parce qu'il
va nous on va être pris par le temps
sinon les propositions qui vous semblent
avoue prioritaire en dehors de ces
questions de sécurité d'immigration on
peut voir notamment dans l'est dans les
propositions le report de l'âge de la
retraite alléger l'impôt sur la fortune
immobilière aussi ou encore supprimer la
redevance pour mettre fin et là je cite
à une machine de propagande quelles sont
les propositions qui vous semblent
importantes l'industrialisation de la
france ça c'est quelque chose de
fondamental on a démantelé la france ça
fait très voyez tout ça on revient quand
on revient on repart de la globalisation
de l'immigration massive qui nivelle
tous les peuples tous des peuples en
souffrent et quand on voit là la façon
dont on a démantelé la france la france
à la découpe un très bon bouquin bon
c'est quelque chose de scandaleux quand
on quand on aime la france annonce est
vrai que certaines et quand ça me fait
penser au monsieur qui habite
actuellement à l'elysée et qui en
lorsqu'il était candidat a dit qu'il n'y
avait pas de culture française mais
quand on est épris de la culture
française on ne peut pas supporter que
ce peuple perdre sa langue d'intérêt sin
contente à déboulonner des des statuts
de personnes qui ont marqué l'histoire
et qui ont été importantes dans
l'histoire on ne peut pas éradiquer
l'histoire immédiate et ça n'existe pas
on peut pas on peut pas ignorer
l'histoire reviendra toujours c'est un
essai terrible de ne pas accepter son
histoire alors maintenant il est il de
l'otan l'expérience aussi on peut avoir
un regard sans réécrire l'histoire mais
avoir un regard différent sur l'histoire
et
évoluer aussi tout simplement s'enrichir
des années passées c'est le principe
même de l'histoire ça c'est à dire c'est
vraiment de tenir compte d'un et mais le
souci c'est que maintenant on a un
regard qui n'est pas du tout un objectif
qui est délibérément critiques c'est à
dire que maintenant on va analyser
certaines parties de l'histoire d'une
façon en effet la prod anisation par
exemple on va dire oui c'était
présentable dalal esclavage triangulaire
en oubliant qu'il na li té c'est vrai
mais ce qui a duré combien tu envie mais
il faudra remettre en perspective dans
l'histoire c'est à dire qu'en 2d sur la
jambe et la vie aussi alors on part sur
ce sujet là mais si on avait demandé
aussi à la vie aux esclaves aux
personnes victimes du commerce
triangulaire pense plutôt qu'elle aurait
souhaité que ça s'arrête plutôt que de
dire qu'il y avait des bienfaits mais
c'est normalement on va d'aujourd'hui
vous évidemment mais après on demande à
l'historien d'avoir une vision beaucoup
plus général et c'est à dire aussi de
comparer dans le temps c'est à dire que
l' esclavage triangulaire a été une
horreur c'était il y avait bon il faut
pas faire non plus d'un acronyme parce
que c'était une époque qu'on n'avait pas
la même vision de la vie de la mort tout
ça c'était quand même quelque chose de
très différent mais c'est de toute façon
absolument abominable je suis tout à
fait d'accord en rond mais il ya
d'autres types d' esclavage qui dure
encore ça moi je pense que c'est
important aussi de dénoncer ce qui se
passe actuellement vous voyez est encore
des choses terribles qui se passe il va
nous rester juste quelques minutes
voudrais parler pour la fin de cet
entretien de l'organisation justement
vous vouliez évoqué tout à l'heure votre
votre votre niveau de l'équipe
sur la campagne présidentielle sur la
campagne législative comme on va se
mettre en place justement votre équipe
vous avez vous évoqué de nom de
personnalités des yvelines qui avait qui
vous ont rejoint le concert jean
frédéric poisson ou lens trochut qui
était auparavant affiliés en tout cas
qu'ils soutenaient les républicains
comment ça s'organise au sein de votre
équipe pour cette campagne pour ces sept
centaines de prochains jours avant le
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle écoutez d'abord nous
sommes partis vraiment du terrain nous
avons un souci de proximité avec les
français un peu à l'image de notre
candidat qui parle quand même tu es
démocratie directe déjà dans son
programme il évoque les référendums en
sachant que cette fois ça sera pas un
référendum fantoches
donc on est proche des français proche
des circonscriptions des 10 équipes par
circonscription et donc il ya un
référent par circonscription les équipes
s'organisent et donc c'est le souci de
subsidiarité c'est à dire que bon je
suis référente des yvelines maintenant
je veux évidemment les référents des
circonscriptions ont une latitude
importante le but étant d'organiser
d'une façon autonome des actions
militantes et aussi surtout surtout de
faire remonter les aspirations les
souhaits les critiques des gens du
terrain ça on insiste beaucoup sur cette
partie de sur cette partie de notre
organisation parce qu'on veut que c'est
encore une fois que ce soit organique on
veut on veut pas que sa seconde on ne
veut pas être un parti comme les autres
avec
uniquement notre notre candidat tu sais
quand d'après symantec parce que notre
candidat est trop important et ne se
résume pas qu'à sa candidature il
englobe aussi la france son histoire et
le souci de proximité avec les français
et de retrouver leur leur souhait de
leur redonner la parole vous savez ce
qui nous intéresse surtout ce sont les
abstentionnistes
c'est silencieux moi vous évoquez une
expérience ponctuelle que je viens avec
florian philippot et j'ai eu l'occasion
dans des cadres beaucoup plus
associative de distribuer beaucoup de
prospectus dans ma vie j'aime beaucoup
ça on rencontre les gens je peux vous
assurer qu'il ya une attente très
importante les français sont pas heureux
beaucoup de français seront pauvres il
ya une grosse différence je vous
apprends rien entre les
et comment dire des bobos 1 et les
français de terrain est ce qu'on appelle
la france périphérique mais qui sont
perdus cela on va les écouter dans les
entendre sur organisation dernier mot
les candidats candidate pour les
législatives sont déjà en train d'être
désigné sur le département des yvelines
non pas du tout se savait sais pas je
pense que c'est pas du tout d'actualité
pour l'instant c'est alors il faut que
des gens se préparent dans leur tête il
faut des gens compétents il faut pas
refaire ce qui a déjà été fait
malheureusement et des gens qui viennent
que pour un titre il faut sont encore
une fois comme eric zemmour comme comme
notre volonté nous de reconquête se
maîtrise de cette étreinte et l'histoire
des français et ses campagnes militants
devant le permettre je me rendis là où
même les législatives a dit oumar et de
votre décision bon signe dans ma tête
déjà dans un non non je non non non mais
je vous répondrais très sincèrement
qu'il ya quelqu'un de plus compétent que
moi qui a plus d'expérience je
laisserais bien la place et si je pense
que je peux y aller j'irai mais si pour
l'instant ce n'est pas du tout
d'actualité je ne pense qu'à l'élection
présidentielle et je ne veux que je
pense aussi après je passe vous mentir
tout le monde pense à prête parce que il
faut pas un poste après l'élection
présidentielle
on se retrouve avec une équipe qui doit
revoir il faudra de toute façon il se
présente aux législatives
à chaque étape ça sera pour le mieux de
reconquête c'est tout merci on va
s'interrompre maintenant pour pour cet
entretien on aura l'occasion de revenir
sur cette campagne des présidentielles
et bien évidemment des législatives sur
notre antenne dans les yvelines merci
alors geste est revenu en plateau
référente du parti reconquête dans les
yvelines
[Musique]